bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour les cours les cours de
paléontologie de l'été notre fil rouge
habituel de l'été depuis trois ans
maintenant c'est la tradition l'été est
consacrée à quelques cours de
paléontologie
le niveau est toujours le même en honors
c'est à dire le cet intervalle qui
n'existe pas en france entre la licence
iii et le master 1 et aujourd'hui on va
voir la biostratigraphie alors c'est un
pré requis avant secours d'avoir vu les
cours de paléontologie des vertébrés
quand je fais secours avec mes étudiants
au nord on fait d'abord la paléontologie
des vertébrés pour ensuite culminé avec
la biostratigraphie du caroux la
biostratigraphie du caroux étant
vraiment là
la cerise sur le gâteau de tout ce qu'on
construit en fait pendant ces cours de
paléontologie des vertébrés les cours de
paléontologie nevers des vertébrés ne
servent que à conduire à la
biostratigraphie du caroux j'ai envie de
dire comme ça on peut là directement
allé tout de suite à la biostratigraphie
sans avoir à s'arrêter à chaque fois sur
chacun des fossiles et à expliquer ce
que chacun des fossiles est donc c'est
un prérequis j'ai envie de dire d'avoir
vu les cours de paléontologie des
vertébrés avant de commencer secours sis
maintenant ce qu'est ce que la
biostratigraphie les biens c'est la
façon de dater les fossiles de façon
relative au moins deux dates et les
roches de façon relative en fonction des
fossiles qu'ils contiennent
si vous voulez savoir comment date les
fossiles de façon absolue c'est à dire
comment on met un âge dessus nous avons
une autre vidéo pour ça que je vous mets
en descriptions nous avons fait une
vidéo sur la datation absolue avec des
spécialistes de la datation absolue
vidéo qui a eu qui n'a pas du tout eu un
succès retentissant d'ailleurs donc je
vous invite à aller la voir vraiment
c'est une vidéo qui est très très
intéressante si vous aimez les cours de
paléontologie vous aimerez cette vidéo
là parce qu'elle est très longue donc et
vous apprendrez tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir sur la datation absolue mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va faire c'est de
la datation relative
on va utiliser les fossiles pour dater
les roches les unes par rapport aux
autres de façon relative sans pour
autant leur camp
un âge définitif la façon dont on leur
colle à nages définitive c'est la
datation absolue
c'est cette autre vidéo voilà donc sans
plus attendre la biostratigraphie du car
ou alors je rappelle que le caroux c'est
ce grand bassin qui se trouve c'est ce
grand bassin qui se trouve au coeur de
l'afrique du sud je vous montrerai une
carte tout à l'heure je croyais qu'il y
avait une quinte sur la diapo d'après
mais en fait non je les enlever juste
avant donc c'est ce grand bassin qui se
trouvent en afrique du sud qui qui
couvre à peu près 100 millions d'années
d'histoire de la vie depuis le permien
le début du permien jusqu'à jusqu'au
début du jurassique
mais déjà commençons par définir ce
qu'est la biostratigraphie donc comme je
les dis là biostratigraphie sert à dater
les roches de façon relativement bas
corréler les strates les unes aux autres
en fonction de leur contenu fossilifère
donc pour ça on va se baser sur ce qui
s'appelle la loi de 6000 de similitude
de similarité des fossiles selon comment
vous traduisez donc cette loi de
similitude des fossiles bas elle dit
tout simplement que si deux sachant que
les espèces évoluent constamment et
s'éteignent constamment si de roche
pourtant différente a priori contiennent
le même fossile donc la même espèce
fossile
sachant que les espèces évoluent et
changent constamment il ya de fortes
chances que ces deux roches se soit
formée en même temps c'est à dire au
moment où cette espèce était vivante
voilà tout simplement donc cette loi de
similitude des fossiles elle permet du
coup de rapprocher des roches qui sont
en apparence différente donc et c'est ce
qui est représenté sur cette petite
figure ici vous avez par exemple les
huîtres bleus on va appeler ça on va
appeler ces trucs là là des huîtres
bleus ici vous avez des huîtres bleus
dans un type de roche
ici vous avez des huîtres bleus dans un
autre type de roche est ici vous avez
encore des huîtres bleus dans un autre
type de roche différents et pourtant ces
huîtres bleus ben il ya tout tout donne
à penser que a priori elles ont vécu en
même temps donc soit la même espèce
d'huîtres bleus avec eux a dit
en droit à différents moments soit on
part du principe qu'elle son véhicule et
en même temps mais qu'elles se sont
juste déposé fossilisé dans des roches
différentes donc la loi de six minutes
des fossiles qu'on applique fait
l'hypothèse a priori que ces huîtres
bleus ont tout vécu en même temps donc
encore elle et ça nous donne sa voix là
on courait les huîtres bleus ensemble et
ensuite bas on vérifie si notre
hypothèse est juste ou pas à savoir qui
est ce que est ce que on observe ensuite
la même succession du fossile avec
d'autres fossiles donc au dessus des
huîtres bleus normalement on est censé
les épines verte
voyez donc on trouve des épines verte
dans différents types de roches
donc j'ai ici c'est un type de roche ici
c'est encore un type de roche différents
est-ce que c'est épique vertes sont
toujours au dessus des huîtres bleus
dans ce nouvel dans cette nouvelle
corrélation de roche
voilà la réponse est oui et au dessus
des épines verte on trouve les escargots
rouge
est-ce qu'on retrouve toujours les
escargots rouge au même endroit la
réponse est oui
donc en fait les la succession c'est la
succession en fait des faunes qui va
nous indiquer si notre corrélation a du
sens
ou pas et puis par dessus on va y
appliquer des datations absolu et c'est
datation absolue elles vont aussi
valider ou non nos corrélation ce qu'on
va voir à la fin de ce cours qui lie à
des limitations quand même à 7 à cette
loi de similitude des fossiles il ya
quand même des défauts ça marche pas
mais ça on le verra à la fin
on va en parler tout à la fin pour
l'instant on va partir du principe que
ça marche
dans tous les cas et mais ce qu'il faut
bien retenir c'est que c'est cette loi
de similitude des fossiles elle n'a rien
d'absolu il va falloir l'a vérifié en
regardant que la succession des fossiles
soit et cohérente et on va au devoir l'a
vérifié avec des datations absolue les
datation absolue c'est le test ultime de
nos corrélation si les datation absolue
ne donne pas d âge qui sont cohérents
avec les successions de faune que nous
donne la biostratigraphie
c'est que il y en a un au moins des 2
qui est faux donc voilà il va bien
falloir et en plus on va faire ça sur
différents bassins
donc aujourd'hui on va parler du bassin
du caroux mais à chaque fois je vais
vous donner des exemples de comment ça a
été appliquée dans d'autres bassins et à
chaque fois ça nous donne des résultats
qui sont quand même cohérent
donc voilà il faut vérifier comme ça les
cohérences à l'intérieur du bassin dans
l'ain succès sur des faunes entre les
différents bassins et dans les
successions de faune et par dessus ça
avec la la datation absolue donc là
biostratigraphie ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est que c'est un outil qui est
très très très très très utile quand on
a rien de mieux
clairement mais c'est un outil qui n'est
pas complètement auto suffisant voilà
quand vous entendez par exemple des
créationnistes se plaindre que les
paléontologues date les fossiles avec
d'autres fossiles c'est parce que c'est
créationnistes n'ont pas compris en fait
que la biostratigraphie nageur n'est pas
et n'a jamais été considéré comme un
outil autosuffisant la biostratigraphie
seule ne suffit pas c'est mais par
contre sur le terrain c'est extrêmement
utile c'est un outil de terrain là
biostratigraphie en fait c'est quand
vous vous promenez dans la nature que
vous trouvez des fossiles immédiatement
le fait de savoir où ce fossile se place
dans la colonne de stratigraphique ça
vous donne immédiatement une indication
de l'âge de la roche approximatif on va
dire donc c'est un outil essentiellement
de terrain mais après quand on revient
en labo quand on revient quand on
revient à l'université il faut faire ses
devoirs et il faut vérifier que notre
hypothèse a priori qu'on a fait sur le
terrain se vérifie ensuite sur le papier
quoi donc à partir de cette loi de
similitude de fossiles on va créer ce
qu'on appelle des biozone donc les
biozone bas ce sont par exemple la
biozone arbitre bleus la biozone à
epinay à épines verte ou la biozone à
escargots rouge
voilà donc on va créer des pires zones
qui sont des zones d'assemblage
on trouve des fossiles particulier dont
on fait l'hypothèse qu'ils sont corrélés
en europe on a par exemple les bio
zonation un mammifère qui ont été faites
comme ça pendant tous le nez aux gènes
et même dans le palais aux jeunes donc
on a un assemblage d assemblage
d'espèces de mammifères qui sont
indicatifs d'une certaine tranche d'âge
voilà et ça c'est une biozone une faune
une faune et une flore qui est
indicative d'une certaine tranche d'âge
et pour ça on va se baser sur des
fossiles qu'on appelle des fossiles
stratigraphique ou des index fossiles en
anglais sont donc ces fossiles
stratigraphique ces marqueurs
biostratigraphie qu'en fait ça va être
des faux cils qui sont plus importants
que d'autres
pour créer ces biozone et ses faux cils
ils vont avoir quatre propriétés
fondamentales qu'ils vont en faire de
très bons marqueurs la première c'est
l'abondance pour avoir un bon fossiles
bon marqueur de bio zone
il faut que notre fossiles soit abondant
parce que si vous allez sur le terrain
encore une fois la biostratigraphie
c'est essentiellement un outil de
terrain donc si vous avez sur le terrain
et que vous êtes un foutu de trouver le
fossile en question votre fosse il ne
sert à rien c'est un marqueur bios
stratigraphique nul donc on veut qu'ils
soient abondantes déjà deuxièmement
votre fossiles
on a intérêt à le trouver un peu partout
l'intérêt être géographiquement très
avoir une grande aire de répartition
d'avril parce que encore une fois si
vous allez sur le terrain et que votre
fossiles
on en trouve que 1 dans un seul coin du
monde ça sert à rien vous n'arriverez
pas à corréler les différentes roches
que vous avez à travers du à travers le
monde
le principe de la biozone nation c'est
d'arriver à corréler des roches
mais si vous trouvez pas votre possible
dans différentes roches sa troisième
propriété il faut que stratigraphique
mans ce fossile est le plus le temps de
vie le plus court possible
ça c'est alors ça c'est une propriété
qui doit être relativisée j'ai envie de
dire parce que dans une certaine manière
les trilobites sont des marqueurs
stratigraphique du paléozoïque m
paléozoïque c'est quand même une énorme
étant du temps et les ammonites sont des
marqueurs bio stratigraphique du
mésozoïque et le pareil le mésozoïque
c'est une énorme étant du temps donc
tout dépend en fait de laitages que vous
que vous cherchez à définir mais
globalement on est quand même plus
intéressés par des marqueurs
stratigraphique de shorts de courte
durée tout simplement parce que ça
permet d'être plus précis voilà c'est
tout c'est vrai que si vous avez par
exemple une vous avez une couche entière
de roche et que toute cette roche c'est
exactement la même roche et de base en
vous prenez un calcaire par exemple mais
que dans ce calcaire dans cette dans ce
banc de calcaire da vous arrivez à
définir quatre biozone parce que il ya
quatre différentes faune qui s'y
succèdent
bon ben j'ai envie de dire c'est bingo
quoi c'est le gros lot c'est que vous
êtes capable de diviser un banc en 4
biozone et vous êtes capable de faire ça
sur une grande étendue c'est c'est ce
qu'on cherche à faire avec la
biostratigraphie quoi est la dernière
chose c'est que toujours parce que la
bio stratigraphie est essentiellement un
outil de terrain faut que votre fossiles
soit facile à identifier
parce que si votre fossiles il n'est pas
facile à identifier si votre fossiles il
faut absolument faire systématiquement
trois ans d'études poussées sur la sur
le caillou pour arriver à l'identifier
qui font ou alors qu'il ya qu un seul
spécialiste au monde qui est capable de
les identifier
bavette marqueur biostratigraphie qui
sert à rien faut que votre fossiles vous
soyez capable de l'identifier pim pam au
premier coup d'oeil
sinon votre votre fossiles il est tout
pourri voilà donc les marques et amp de
stratigraphie c'est à ça qu'on les
reconnaît abondance abondance grande
zone géographique
petite zone stratigraphique est facile à
identifier et là vous avez le parfait
marqueur bio stratigraphique alors
d'habitude je rajoute là mais
apparemment je les ai enlevés il ya
aussi le principe qui consiste basse et
la loi d'évolution en fait c'est que on
utilise aussi dans la biostratigraphie
ça notamment été fait en france
c'est peut-être parce que ça n'a jamais
été fait en afrique du sud donc j'ai dû
le virer le
j'ai dû virer cette phrase là mais il ya
aussi la loi de dévolution ou en fait on
utilise certaines tendances évolutives
pour arriver à dater les roches
relativement aux autres donc ça a été
beaucoup fait par exemple dans le quercy
avec les rongeurs les rongeurs de
l'éocène à l'oligocène donc on sait que
chez les rongeurs de l'éocène à
l'oligocène on a une évolution une
adaptation en fait des rongeurs à un
mode de vie dans un milieu plus ouvert
donc un milieu
donc ils sont partis en fait d'un milieu
forestier pour arriver à un milieu
beaucoup plus ouvert beaucoup plus de
savane et cette adaptation elle se
retranscrit sur le corps des rongeurs et
notamment sur l'étang des rongeurs par
une augmentation de la couronne dentaire
donc plus ils s'adaptent à manger de
l'herbe en gros et plus leur couronne
plus la couronne de leurs dents de leurs
mollets redevient haute parce qu'ils
résistent en fait à l'abrasion de
appliquée par l'herbe sur leurs dents et
donc on peut arriver à dater les roches
en fonction de cette tendance évolutive
c'est à dire que plus vous trouvez des
rongeurs dans qui ont une couronne haute
et plus vous savez que vous êtes dans
des rangs dans des roches jeunes est au
contraire plus vous trouvez des rongeurs
à couronne basse 1 couronne dentaire
basse et plus vous savez que vous êtes
dans des roches vieilles donc c'est
notamment la série des ischios remise
qui est très très très connu dans le
terreau ci est donc ça s'appelle la loi
d'évolution donc si on se met par contre
encore une fois ça implique d'avoir
d'abord établi qu'il y avait une
tendance évolutive et donc d'avoir des
datation absolue pour montrer que cette
tendance évolutive est une réalité
et puis ça implique de se baser sur une
seule et unique ligne et donc avoir
établi que cette lignée et
phylogénétiquement une réalité donc faut
ça implique des grosses conditions
mais ça ça n'a jamais été appliquée de
toute façon dans le contexte
sud-africain donc c'est pour ça je pense
que je les enlever donc voilà en
pratique
à quoi ça doit ressembler des biozone
donc là la biozone j'ai envie de dire la
plus parfaite c'est la biozone
towns ici c'est à dire un fossile une
biozone simple efficace généralement ça
se passe pas comme ça généralement vous
avez un assemblage de fossiles égale une
bio zone donc là par exemple ça c'est là
le type de bio zone le plus typique
qu'on a dans le karoo la assemblage zone
donc la zone d'assemblage ou là vous
avez par exemple c'est le chevauchement
en fait entre ce fossile da et ce
fossile da qui va vous donner l'âge de
la roche donc elle a les étudiants faut
beaucoup l'erreur en fait de s'imaginer
que si on trouve ces deux fossiles en
fait ensemble dans une même roche alors
la roche peut être deux cet âge là cet
âge là où cet âge là mais là avec cette
représentation on voit très très bien
tout de suite que si on trouve les deux
fossiles dans la même roche laroche ne
peut être que de cet âge là et c'est
tout donc exemple tout simple ainsi vous
trouvez si vous trouvez asselain quand
avec un megalodon alors souvent les
étudiants ils font l'erreur de dire le
coelacanthe il existe depuis le début
lien alors du coup la rochelle peut être
du dévonien jusqu'au miocène non non si
vous avez megalodon megalodon il n'était
pas là au dévonien
donc si vous par contre le coelacanthe y
en avait encore au dévonien
donc il y en avait encore au miocène
donc votre rochelle et mios n oublie
hossein est donc faux faut faire
attention à comment on joue avec ses
biozone bon mais là au moins c'est
visuel on voit immédiatement que voilà
c'est le chevauchement qui définit la
biozone ici dans cette zone d'assemblage
et après vous allez avoir d'autres
fossiles qui vont plus ou moins
s'ajouter à sa une variation sur le
terrain sur la sur la biozone
d'assemblage ça va être pas la biozone
partial range donc ici c'est plutôt
l'absence de certains fossiles qui vont
vous indiquer une biozone on en a pas
dans le karoo est ici vous avez la
fameuse tendance évolutive les
conséquences ivrogne bayod zone donc ça
s'est basée sur la loi d'évolution c'est
à dire que vous avez succession dessus
une tendance évolutive en fait qui fait
changer votre espèce à en espèces b en
espèces et et on sait là en l'occurrence
c'est l'espèce b qui définit la biozone
donc là si vous aviez des rongeurs vous
auriez les rongeurs à couronne dentaire
basse couronne dentaire intermédiaire
couronne dentaire haute et vous aurez
votre bios zone qui sera défini ici
comme étant la biozone où les rongeurs
ont une couronne dentaire intermédiaire
j'ai envie de dire que c'est à double
tranchant parce que plus votre tendance
évolutive sera bien documenté et plus ça
va être difficile de définir des bio
zone
mais bon là après ou alors si vous avez
vraiment une tendance évolutive qui est
très très très remarquée et très très
bien documenté au contraire la hauteur
dentaire sera immédiatement corrélée
avec le avec la stratigraphie mais bref
donc ça c'est ça c'est le type de bio
zone qui est immédiatement inspiré
justement de la loi de des faunes
consécutive et vous avez le dernier type
de bio zone qui est utilisé dans le
karoo et c'est la biozone basé sur
l'abondance
donc on a au moins deux bios zone dans
le karoo qui sont basés pas sur une
abondance de fossiles c'est sur une
abondance d'un certain fossiles en
particulier donc il est là avant il est
là après mais le fait qu'on en trouve
d'un seul coup une tonne ça permet de
définir une bio zone et ça encore une
fois sa part du principe que on va faire
l'hypothèse que cette espèce en
particulier a eu un grand succès à un
moment et que ce grand succès a été
universel universel au point de vue
géographique je veux dire et a été très
court dans le temps et synchrones
du coup bon bah ça ça c'est des
hypothèses qu'on fait a priori et comme
j'ai dit après faut les tester avec des
datations absolue donc je ne peux que je
ne saurais trop insister pour que vous
alliez voir la vidéo sur la datation
absolue
ben c'est pas vraiment ça me semble
aussi un prérequis assez importants ou
alors même après le court stratigraphie
vous pouvez aller voir sur cette vidéo
sur la datation absolue parce que ça
vraiment ça travaille ensemble labios
pratique
raffi et la datation absolue ce ne sont
pas deux outils complètement opposées et
puis vous avez des tenants de la
datation absolue et détonnant de la
datation relative non non c'est vraiment
deux outils qui doivent travailler
ensemble et les deux doivent donner des
résultats cohérents pour fonctionner
quoi voilà maintenant pourquoi est-ce
qu'on utiliserait la biostratigraphie
c'est à dire pourquoi on n'utiliserait
pas tout le temps et datation absolue
déjà les datation absolue on ne peut pas
les faire partout comme on veut la
datation absolue c'est compliqué à faire
généralement il faut au moins une couche
volcanique ou quelque chose comme ça
pour arriver à en tirer des ce qu'il
faut quand même une certaine faut une
fois des particules radioactives pour
arriver à faire de la datation absolue
et on les trouve pas partout on n'y
trouve pas tout le temps en grande
quantité dans le karoo on utilise par
exemple et zircon et les ir qu'on s'est
pas toujours évident de trouver les
meilleurs zircon ils viennent des roches
volcaniques
or des roches volcaniques y en a pas
tout le temps dans le cas où il n'y a
pas dans le volcan il n'y a pas eu de
cas roues avant la fin du jurassique
avant le début du jurassic park donc en
afrique du sud il ya quelques couches
volcanique en afrique du sud qui
viennent de volcans qui était à l'époque
en amérique du sud
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on a comme comme
événement volcaniques dans le karoo
avant le jurassique donc les couches
volcaniques sont rares et après on
trouve des zircons de moins bonne
qualité dans les grès donc dans les
roches qui sont faites de sable un durée
mais c'est zircon ce sont des zircons
qui ont été remaniés donc c'est des
zircons qui ont été qui viennent de
roches plus ancienne et qui ont été
reprises dans des rivières qui ont été
érodées par des rivières et redéposés
dans des lits de rivières et ça c'est
problématique parce que du coup ce désir
qu'ont ils ont l'âge de leur premier
dépôt or nous on les trouve dans une
roche qui a été déposée plus tard donc
il ya à chaque fois ils vont nous donner
un âge plus vieux que le que l'âge de la
rolls dans lesquelles on les a trouvés
si on utilise une datation absolue
dessus donc il y a une grosse marge
d'erreur sur saisir qu'ont donc pourquoi
on utilise la biostratigraphie tout
simplement parce que la datation absolue
ça
peut pas se faire tout le temps comme on
veut d'une et de deux parce que les
datations absolue elles ont une marge
d'erreur aussi voilà surtout si vous
utilisez des zircons détritiques donc
issus des grès donc déjà premièrement
deuxièmement pourquoi on utilise la
biostratigraphie va encore une fois
c'est un outil de terrain c'est pour
savoir où on est parce que quand vous
êtes dans le karoo vous êtes face à une
surface qui fait à peu près la moitié de
la surface de la france qui est
complètement ou presque complètement
désertique qui est tout ou presque tout
géologiquement se ressemblent donc dit
si par exemple vous ai mis des photos du
permis à moyens en bas à gauche du
permien supérieur au milieu et du trias
en haut à droite
voilà c'est de l'alternance marno
gréseuses grisâtre verdâtre bleuâtre ou
rougeâtre à perte de vue
comment vous repérez là dedans
le dire que voilà vous avez pas vous
avez quand quand vous êtes lâchés là
dedans que vous essayez de comprendre ce
qui se passe géologiquement vous n'allez
pas faire des petits trous partout en
essayant de en espérant faire de la de
la datation absolue à tous les coins de
rue en fait c'est ça le truc si vous
n'allez pas faire de la datation absolue
sur chacune de chacun des bandes grella
qui ce qui s'offre à vous vous ne vous
ne vous en sortirez jamais vous voulez
un outil qui est utilisable
immédiatement et dont et qui peut être
utilisée par des moyens humains
j'ai envie de dire donc vous allez
utiliser la pio stratigraphie vous allez
utiliser le contenu en fossiles et quand
vous regardez le contenu en fossiles du
permien moyen du père bien supérieur et
du trias cela vous trouver des fossiles
très différents les uns des autres
très abondant est très facilement
identifiable et là ça devient pratique
et ce sont des fossiles qu'on retrouve
dans tout le bassin du caroux et même
dans les bassins à vous voisins et même
dans des bassins jusque dans
l'hémisphère nord
donc là vous avez un outil qui est
pratique et qui est applicable
immédiatement quand vous êtes sur le
terrain quand vous essayez de comprendre
ce que vous avez en face de vous voilà
donc parce que sinon bah le quart ou
c'est juste de l'alternance marno
gréseuses à perte de vue et vous vous en
sortirez jamais si vous utilisez si vous
croyez utiliser la couleur pour vous en
sortir parce que je pense que j'imagine
bien que là les gens ont remarqué que le
trias avait l'air un peu plus rouge que
les autres alors oui le trias est un peu
plus rouge dans certains coins pas dans
tous pas partout donc voilà on va mais
on va faire le détail de tout ça et mais
en tout cas voilà c'est pour bien
comprendre que la biostratigraphie 7,1
quand on est étudiant j'ai envie de dire
en tout cas moi quand j'étais étudiant
j'avais tendance à me dire mais pourquoi
on fait pas de la datation absolue tout
le temps c'est ridicule voilà bah quand
on te lâche là au milieu du caroux et
qu'on te dit vas-y maintenant avec
l'annotation absolue dis moi où on est
bah voila quand le site a pas si tu
connais pas déjà la datation absolue du
coin ou tuer ben à part utilisé lés faux
cils tu peux rien faire d'autre
est ce qu'il ya de bien c'est qu'on a
déjà fait de l'adaptation absolution
certains fossiles dont il ya certains
fossiles dont on sait qu'ils ont une
certaine durée de vie on a déjà leur
durée de vie donc on n'a pas besoin de
faire de la datation absolue donc à tous
les coins de rue justement à partir du
moment où on sait la durée de vie d'un
certain taxons fossiles
on est capable d'appliquer cette durée
de vie à d'autres endroits quand on
trouve dans d'autres endroits et même
dans d'autres bassins
c'est le principe de la biozone nation
c'est le principe de la biozone donc là
ce que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui est bien celle à la bio
stratigraphie de du bassin du carreau
donc ça y est la voilà cette fameuse
carte du car vous voyez la carte de
l'afrique du sud et donc le caroux c'est
la partie colorée au milieu donc c'est
la biostratigraphie du caroux telle
qu'elle a été rétablie en 2021 il
n'existe à ma connaissance aucune
publication en français qui parle de la
biostratigraphie du carreau à part
peut-être le
les traités de mammalogie les traités de
paléo mammalogique piffeteau avait
publié en 1951 donc donc autant dire que
si vous aimez pas la littérature
anglophone où vous risquez de vous
ennuyer tout cas vous risquez de pointe
à jour ceci dit la pio stratigraphie du
carreau a été établi en 1800 et des fin
des années 1800 par six lits a été
ensuite retravaillé par brou maudit au
début des années 1900 et puis ensuite a
été retravaillé très régulièrement par
d'autres chercheurs kitchen rogers smith
bruce rugby jo donc c'est quelque chose
qui a été dit et j'ai été assez souvent
mais au final les grandes lignes de la
biostratigraphie du carreau en 1951 au
final elle était déjà relativement bien
établie maintenant c'est on est vraiment
en train de fignoler les détails j'ai
envie de dire et lalla maintenant on a
des détails absolument exquis des cartes
extrêmement détaillée de la
biostratigraphie du caroux donc qu'ils
sont qui sont du coup donné dans ce
nouveau volume que je vous affiche à
l'écran qu'il est sorti en 2020 et donc
le cours que j'ai mis là c'est la
version la version update basé sur cette
nouvelle publication
géographiquement le caroux c'est un
exercice intéressant de l'étudier parce
que c'est un bassin qui a une structure
géologique relativement simple
déjà vous pouvez voir là je vous ai
afficher la section en eaux
donc de ce bassin du carreau donc une
section qui part d'ici un an
donc au sud ouest jusqu'au nord-est et
cette section dont elle passe à travers
le lesotho et en fait on se rend compte
que déjà vu du dessus en fait les
couches du caroux l'ailé biozone
ducarouge sont en cercles concentriques
autour du lesotho c'est à dire que les
bio zones qui sont les plus loin du
lesotho c'est celle là notamment la zone
a et audi synodaux sont plus vieilles
que les bio zones qui sont autour
immédiatement autour du lesotho donc ici
vous démarrez donc dans ce coin du car
on vous démarrez
ont permis un moyen et d'ailleurs vous
avez le autour de ça vous avez le eca
groupe
un pardon le douy cas groupe qui est le
plus ancien qui va même jusqu'au
jusqu'au père bien inférieur donc vous
allez du permien inférieur au permis un
moyen puis au père bien supérieur puis
au trias et jusqu'au début du jurassique
avec les bios zones qui sont le plus
proches du lesotho le lesotho lui même
étant un volcan en fait qui est arrivé
au milieu du caroux le lesotho lui-même
c'est un volcan en fait le pays du
lesotho est un volcan qui forment un
relief en fait sur lequel le peuple
passe où tous ces réfugiés pendant la
guerre entre les entre les anglais les
zoulous en fait ils se sont retrouvés
pris entre les deux feux ils se sont
réfugiés sur les montagnes et les
montagnes en fait c'est le drakensberg
qu'on appelle le drag and the berg et
ses montagnes se sont en fait un ancien
volcan du début du jurassique qui a
poussé par dessus le caroux a répandu
ces laves partout sur le carreau et a
scellé le bassin du carreau pendant des
centaines de millions d'années jusqu'à
ce que l'érosion ray expose les roches
du cargo donc vous avez cette
disposition du caroux qui est donc en
cercles concentriques avec les cercles
du milieu plus jeunes que les cercles
autour donc c'est une structure qui est
en synclinal synclinal avec un s comme
sourire voilà si vous voulez vous rendre
retenir contrairement à anticlinal qui
commence par un a donc une structure
comme ça le contraire d'un sacre final
ça commence par un des signes commun
voilà donc là c'est une structure en
synclinal avec les couches les plus
vieilles au tour et les couches les plus
jeunes au milieu le tout centré autour
du lesotho donc là montagnes du
drakensberg qui est le volcan qui a
scellé le bassin au début du jurassique
et quand on fait une section du coup à
travers ce bassin est bien ce qu'on
constate c'est que le bassin et plus
fins au nord-est qu'il ne l'est au sud
ouest
et ça c'est du diverses mouvements
tectoniques essentiellement liée aux
montagnes qui a dans la région du cap
donc le cab qui est au sud ouest du pays
donc le voyez ici la ville du cap qui se
trouvent ici qui est un donc le cap se
trouve au sud ouest du pays et c'est une
en fait la ville se trouve sur une
plaine côtière qui est séparé du bassin
du carreau par une immense montagne
mais cette montagne c'est ce qu'on
appelle la montagne du cap donc là la
montagne des puits du cap cap fall belt
donc le pli du cap qui fait le tour en
fait du car on part par le sud et isole
en fait la plaine côtière du désert du
karoo donc climatiquement c'est une
montagne qui est très importante puisque
au cap au cap vous avez un climat
tempéré voir méditerranéen
vous traversez la montagne de l'autre
côté vous avez un climat désertique
aride ultra sec
enfin vivable donc c'est une montagne
climatiquement elle est hyper important
de cette montagne
c'est ce qui fait la différence et ça et
je veux dire elle est passée pas épaisse
1 c'est pas super épais vous faites une
centaine de kilomètres pour traverser
cette montagne vous passez du caroux
leur l'endroit le plus aride d'afrique
du sud
voilà le kalahari aussi mais un des
endroits les plus arides d'afrique du
sud vous passez du carreau vous
traversez la montagne vous arriver au
cap qui est l'endroit où on fait pousser
des vignes c'est le plus fertile
d'afrique du sud donc donc c'est pas une
n'est pas anecdotique du tout comme
montagne c'est bien de jouer à venir et
donc ses montagnes ses montagnes marque
la limite l'entrée du carré et donc ses
montagnes
elle était déjà là à l'époque de la
formation du bassin du caroux ce sont de
très très vieille montagne des roches
qui date
pas de du cambrien jusqu au dévonien
c'est une très très vieille montagne
c'est donc le jeu des failles dans ces
montagnes qui a fait que le bassin est
plus profond au sud qu'au nord parce que
non il n'y a pas de montagne il n'y
avait pas de montagne avant que le
lesotho avant que le dragon's den berghe
ne se forment donc au nord il y avait
pas de montagne et donc c'est le jeu des
failles dans ces montagnes au sud qui a
permis au bassin de plus profond au sud
qu'au nord donc au nord c'est beaucoup
plus difficile aussi au nord de
d'arriver à avoir de la biostratigraphie
correct parce que du coup c'est beaucoup
plus plat aussi au nord donc c'est
paraître c'est pour ça que vous voyez
aussi beaucoup plus de bio zone au sud
qu'au nord parce que au nord tout est
beaucoup plus plat donc avec beaucoup
moins d'érosion donc il ya beaucoup
moins de d'affleurements qui ont été
érodées et puis à l'érosion est aussi
allé moins profondément et du coup a
exposé beaucoup moins de roche
bref
continuons donc là on va commencer
justement par regarder le doubs icade
oncle louis casser les roches les plus
anciennes ici représentée en marron vous
l'avez une version simplifiée du caroux
ici représentée devant vous mais c'est
toujours la même chose donc le double
cas là ce sont les roches qui sont en
marron ici donc qui font le tour du
caroux donc là vous avez la montagne du
cap ici représentée en bleu foncé les
roches qui sont immédiatement après la
montagne alors ce tweak ah c'est pas le
quart ou le plus typique c'est le
carreau de la fin du carbonifère du
début du permien il a environ 300
millions d'années
bien qu'il ait pas de grosses grosses
dates très solides et c'est en fait ce
sont des dépôts glaciaires donc on y
trouve essentiellement des moraines donc
c'est à dire des roches qui ont été
déposés par les glaciers quand les
glaciers arrivé en fait ils chaillet
desrochers quand ils font des bonds il
laissé tomber leur roche et ses roches
forme des moraines d'éthyle hits comme
les appelle en anglais et le va et vient
des glaciers durant l'heure entre les
saisons ce entre les saisons chaudes et
saison froide contre l'hiver il est elle
a aussi poli certaines surfaces qu'on
appelle des glaïeuls payment et on en a
de très très beaux exemples
ici en afrique du sud par exemple ou là
vous avez vraiment des roches mais qui
ont été polis et strié par les glaciers
on arrive même à voir dessous c'est ce
trait on a elle même avoir la direction
du glacier en fait tellement ces stries
sont régulières et par fait quoi et
c'est sur ces surfaces
ces surfaces polies ont souvent été
utilisées par les bushmen pour faire des
dessins pour faire des gravures
donc en plus en plus d'être des zones
géologiquement intéressant que ce sont
des zones qui sont historiquement aussi
très intéressante
voilà donc tout ça ça nous indique
quelques os carbonifère et au début du
père bien l'afrique du sud elle était
pas loin du tout du pôle sud
ce que vous voyez sur la carte la gauche
l'afrique du sud n'était pas du tout
loin du pôle sud elle était en fait sur
le bord de la doublette des glaciers en
fait qu'ils se gênent et ray elle était
vraiment sur le bord des glaciers quoi
puisque c'est là que les bords n étaient
déposées c'est là que le glacier
avançaient et reculaient et police et la
roche donc en était l'afrique du sud
n'était pas sous la glace peut faire
contes en hiver elle était sous la glace
et on sait que ces glaciers pouvait
aller en hiver jusqu'en antarctique
parce que on a retrouvé des fossiles qui
viennent d'antarctique et qui ont été
ramenés par les glaciers donc par
exemple cet arc et au ciad que vous
voyez en bas c'est un archéo siat qui
était déjà fossilisés au carbonifère et
opère bien c'était déjà un fossile
sauf que il s'est retrouvé dans une mort
n donc dans une roche que le glacier à
emporter d'antarctique et à déposer
ensuite quand il a fondu en afrique du
sud et il l'a déposée au début du permis
a du coup donc il n'y a aucun doute sur
le fait que cet art qu'est hausse at-il
date du cambrien parce que l'on trouve
les archéo siat que au cambrien donc on
sait qu'il était déjà fossilisés à
l'époque et en plus on sait que c'est
pas un arc est aussi là dessus
d'africains parce qu'il n'y a jamais eu
d'arqués au ciad en afrique du sud on a
de très très beaux un très très bon
registre du cambrien en afrique du sud
la montagne de la table c'est des roches
cambriel en afrique du sud
donc la montagne de la table qui est
jean lamontagne la plus connue au monde
c'est
c'est l'une des montagnes les plus
connus au monde le cap est construit au
pied de la montagne
donc il n'y a aucun doute sur le fait
que s'il y avait eu des arcs et aussi
est là dedans on l'aurait su et il y en
a pas donc voilà on sait qu'il ya pas
dark est aussi apte en afrique du sud
par contre donc on est à peu près sûr
que ce que cet arc et au ciad a été
ramené par les glaciers dans les
moraines au permien et qu'il est venu
d'antarctique et donc ça ça montre bien
du coup que le glacier s'étendait
jusqu'en antarctique et puis revenait en
afrique quand il fondait en fait donc
voilà on a quand même une bonne idée
mine de rien grâce aux fossiles de du
genre de mouvement que pouvaient faire
les glaciers mais pour ça ça rentre pas
dans la bio zonation au final puisque ce
sont des indices essentiellement
géologique
donc on va pas passer trop de temps sur
le deux cas on passe les cas donc les
cas c'est la zone légèrement plus marron
clair que vous voyez ici on n'est pas
encore dans le karoo typique celui qui
donne beaucoup beaucoup de fossiles dans
les cas on trouve pas énormément de
fossiles voyez qu'on se rapproche à sa
sauce ayela ça commence à se resserrer
un peu plus on va vers des rôles jeune
et plus on va se resserrer
mais on n'est pas encore dans le karoo
typique donc là ce qu'on trouve ces
maisons aux russes dans les cas et
encore on ne trouve pas dans tous les
cas on le retrouve surtout dans une
formation qui s'appelle la wild field
formation donc la formation colline
blanche parce que la roche dans laquelle
on trouve mais aux orris vous voyez
cette roche noire
en fait quand elle s'altère cette roche
devient blanche donc à l'érosion en fait
la roche devient blanche donc mais aux
eaux russes celle exemplaire le sait le
lotti passé le premier exemplaire de
mezzo russe qui a été découvert il a été
décrit par gervais
dans les années 1860 et quelques et il
est à paris aujourd'hui puisque
l'afrique du sud à l'époque avait des
bonnes relations avec la france donc
donc il est à paris aujourd'hui se met
aux eaux russes est donc c'est le
fossile qui a su qui a aidé wegener à
développer sa théorie de la de la dérive
des continents puisque mais aux russes
on trouve à la fois en afrique du sud
enfin dans le sud de l'afrique pas qu en
afrique du sud
on le trouve à la fois dans le sud de
l'afrique et en amérique du sud
donc c'est le fossile qui historiquement
a permis à vaiges nerfs et dvg nerfs
j'ai envie de dire plutôt à établir sa
théorie de la dérive des continents qui
n'a pas été acceptée à avoir un bon
moment après ça mais bref voilà donc les
cas groupe est du début milieu père bien
voilà c'est pareil on sait pas trop il
ya les datation absolue sont pas sont
pas très abondante pour cette période là
et on trouve d'autres on trouve d'autres
espèces animales et ses espèces animales
sont intéressantes déjà parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de fossiles dans le doubs ce
cas le week-end était purement glacière
et on n'y trouvait pas de fossiles a pas
des faux cils 30 articles qui sont qui
ont été ramenés par les moraines ce et
cas les cas groupe est intéressant parce
qu'on commence à y trouver des fossiles
et on y trouve des fossiles marins donc
notamment des crustacés des poissons et
ces fossiles marins donc nous indique
que les cas à les cas le bassin du
caroux s'est formé ça y est il ya deux
il ya un bassin en fête et ce bassin ben
c'est en fait une mère il est recouvert
par une mer une mer intérieure peu
profondes peu profondes et qui va pas
durer très longtemps
voilà mais il ya des il ya quand même
suffisamment de suffisamment profonde
quand même pour accueillir une faune
marine suffisamment étendu en fait pour
accueillir une faune viable notamment
durant le dépôt de cette webcam fort
méchant donc donc seul cas en fait marc
l'ouverture j'ai envie de dire du bassin
et donc à partir de là on va rentrer
dans le karoo plus typique ce qu'on
appelle le pot fort donc le
groupe beaufort c'est le quart nous
typique celui dont vous entendez parler
à la télé quand on vous parle de la
limite tarja trias par exemple et qu'on
vous dit que les scientifiques sont
allés étudier le carreau en fait ils
sont pas allés étudier les cas et le
douy cas ils sont allés étudier le
beaufort voilà donc ce beaufort qui
tient son nom de la ville de beaufort
ouest qui se trouvent ici vous voyez
quelque part alors le qu'un peu serez là
johannesbourg sorella au alors il ya la
route qui va de johannesburg au cap qui
passent par là par là par la part d'un
par l'appareil comme ça qui va jusqu'au
cap donc là en fait si vous ce qu'on va
faire là aujourd'hui finalement c'est ni
plus ni moins qu'un voyage qui
démarrerait du cap
voilà donc qui démarrait du sud ouest et
puis on va remonter en fait direction
direction johannesbourg en passant au
travers de toutes ces formations de tous
et de toutes ces biozone en fait on va
remonter vers johannesbourg comme
s'attaque en passant par toutes ces
villes donc là on a déjà fait on est
remonté du cap on a déjà travaillé
traverser les cas on a traversé enfin on
a traversé par dont le douy cas et les
cas qui sont indiqués dans la même
couleur ici encore une fois un marron
clair et là on arrive dans le beaufort
où on rencontre la première zone
d'assemblage qui va l'être la zone a et
o 10 6 me dont donc la zone a et
auditionnera les localiser que dans le
sud-ouest du beaufort c'est à dire dans
la partie la plus profonde du bassin du
car vous rappelez vous que c'est le
sud-ouest qui est plus profond donc il
ya que là qu'elle est préservé 7
cette zone a et audi synodaux ici vous
avez un petit tableau qui va qui vous
donne un résumé en gros de toutes les
datations qu'on a pu faire les datations
absolu qu'on a pu faire dans le karoo à
l'heure actuelle c'est le tableau qui
est issu de la publication de 2020 vous
voyez qu'on a beaucoup de dates mais
qu'au final c'est assez peu de dates
quand on y réfléchit bien il n'y a pas
de date par exemple pour tout les débuts
et fandio zone mais en gros on peut dire
que et notamment il n'y a pas de date
pour le début de la zone aride et audi
donc pour l'instant encore qu'il ya des
dates non publiées ici entre la zone à
tapie n'en s'est fallu c'est la zone à
jodie sinon qui date
cette limite a plus ou moins de 164
millions d'années en gros donc on
pourrait estimer que la zone a et audi
synodaux débute à 265 millions d'années
dans l'interrogation est donc là dépôt
de la fin de dépôt du caroux 783
millions d'années donc voyez qu'on
couvre quand même quasiment 100 millions
d'années d'évolution quoi avec ce beau
fort donc ces essais les 100 millions
d'années qui ont vu la diversification
des amniotes donc c'est très très très
important pour la compréhension de
l'évolution des amis attend donc c'est
parti pour la zone a et audi synodaux
donc comme je vous le disais la zone a
et auditionnera elle se situe au sud
ouest du caire où près de l'iceberg donc
là dans notre voyage depuis le cap
jusqu'à jusqu à johannesbourg nous nous
arrêtons à l'iceberg ici voilà à quoi
ressemble la zone a et o 10 6 me dont
donc un truc que j'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure c'est que le car ou c'est un
endroit qui est très très étudiée pour
sa bio zonation notamment parce que les
roches sont relativement horizontale
donc elles sont relativement plate
donc c'était un endroit qui est
géologiquement ça reste quand même assez
facile à comprendre c'est pas comme
c'est bon c'est pas comme le quercy par
exemple en france où là vous avez des
grottes et alors pour corréler des
grottes entrait c'est une cata face et
hyper difficile de corréler des dépôts
des dépôts de grottes entre eux parce
que justement on n'avait aucune
continuité directe entre chaque grotte
quoi en fait donc à chaque fois c'est la
faune et uniquement la faune qui va vous
indiquer la continuité donc le caroux
c'est quand même relativement simple à
étudier parce que les couches sont
relativement horizontale malgré leur
grand âge
rabelais je vous rappelle qu'elles vont
autour de 200 ha autour de 200 à 260
millions d'années donc c'est quand même
de la vieille roche donc hélas avec la
zone a et o d'ici novembre
une des premières choses qui permet de
savoir que vous êtes en train de
regarder la zone a et o des signaux d'en
bas c'est qu'en fait les roches sont pas
horizontale voilà c'est ce que cette
photo est là pour vous illustrer vous
savez plus où moins que vous êtes vous
avez déjà une grande probabilité d'être
en train de regarder de la zone à jodie
si nos dents quand les roches sont pas
spécialement horizontal et ça c'est dû
au fait qu'on est très proche de la
montagne du cap en fait c'est vu qu'on
est très proche de la montagne du câble
basse et des failles qui jouait à
l'époque du carreau qui ont continué à
jouer après le carreau et donc elles ont
laissé les roches à la verticale quoi
donc ça c'est un premier indice et puis
bal après le deuxième indice c'est le
deuxième indice c'est essentiellement de
la faune que vous allez trouver à
l'intérieur donc déjà le un autre indice
que vous êtes en train de regarder la
zone à jodie synodaux c'est que vous
êtes rentré dans le groupe beaufort
c'est à dire qu'on est plus en dépend
marin et le fait d'être de ne plus être
en dépôt marin c'est que vous avez
commencé à rencontrer ce qu'on appelle
des palais au sol c'est à dire des sols
fossilisés comment on sait qu'on regarde
un seul fossilisés bas on va y trouver
des racines ou des concrétions de racine
on va commencer à les trouver des
nodules des nodules carbonatées les
nodules carbonatées qui se forme dans
des sols qui sont secs justement donc le
carbonate s'agglomèrent je suis pas
géologue
donc je ne sais pas exactement comment
ça se former en tout cas je sais que les
nodules carbonates et ça se forment dans
les sols quand ils s'assèche
voilà je crois qu'ils se forment niveau
de la de là
de la nappe phréatique en fait donc il
vous indique les nodules carbonatées en
fait vous indique où était la nappe
phréatique donc mais tout ça ça vous
indique que le solde du coût était sec
donc il n'y avait pas de mer s'il ya une
nappe phréatique fatalement de toute
façon il n'y a pas la mer c'est un peu
logique
bref donc donc vous entrez déjà dans le
beaufort c'est à dire que vous rentrez
en dépôt continental donc vous arrêtez
d'être en dépôt vous arrêter d'être dans
les dépôts marins de l'eca donc ça c'est
le deuxième indice en plus du fait que
c'est quasiment verticale est donc le
troisième à dix ça va être la faune que
vous vouliez rencontrer et le truc le
plus marquant à propos de la faune de la
zone a et audi synodaux c'est que vous
n'avez pas trouvé grand chose
globalement avec tout le temps qu'on a
pu passer nous sur le terrain dans la
zone high et audi sino dont je peux vous
annoncer que c'est une équipe de 10
personnes va trouver un fossile tous les
trois jours
à peu près en moyenne c'est pas un
fossile par personne tous les trois
jours non non non non non non l'équipe
entière de 10 personnes va trouver un
fossile tous les trois jours
les fossiles sont extrêmement rares
enfin évidemment les fossiles les
ossements évidemment les choses qui vont
nous permettre de faire de la bio
strathyre je ne compte pas les bivalves
puisqu'il ya des bivalves d'eau douce
évidemment ça aussi c'est un indice que
vous êtes en milieux continental
d'ailleurs de trouver des bivalves d'eau
douce mais bref voilà donc c'est certain
nombre et qui est assez frustrant la
zone à elodie sinon on n'y trouve pas
beaucoup beaucoup de fossiles mais dans
les fossiles qu'on trouvait bon on
trouve le fameux et audi synodaux dont
qui est un dc nos donc bien
reconnaissable à son bec et à sa défense
et ce d'ici 90 c'est le plus primitif
des dc 90 parce que son bec n'est pas
encore fusionné donc les deux pré
maxillaire ici ne sont pas encore
fusionné et on va y trouver aussi son
petit cousin pateras nous menons qui est
aussi un herbivore comme et audi
synodaux mais lui par contre il a encore
plein de grosses dents à l'arrière
il n'y a pas deux canines et il n'a pas
de grosses dents à l'arrière il a des
petites dents qui ressemble à des petits
jeux pour les petits crayons quoi c'est
des petites dents herbivore quoi assez
classique donc essayer de la battre à
nos maux dont héros dc nos dons sont les
fossiles les plus typiques de la zone à
elodie sim donc avec le dino céphale
tapis nokan innus tapis nokan innus
c'est un très très gros herbivores et
audi sino dont il fait à peu près cette
taille là tapie donc à dennis le crâne
c'est un crâne gigantesque c'est un gros
tapis nos sefa liens de la famille des
dinos et fall donc dit non celle fall
qui veut dire tête terrible parce que
vous voyez ils ont un crâne d'une
épaisseur assez abominable et ils sont
très laide
voilà ils sont magnifiquement très laid
cédilot ses fans voyaient là la barre
post orbitaire et d'une épaisseur assez
incroyable cesser les fameuses animaux
qui se battaient tête contre tête un peu
comme les comme les dinosaures pâquis
ses fans aux orres quoi c'est un peu la
même philosophie mais en version
synapses ide et c'est tapis nokan innus
il est très identifiable au fait que
c'est le seul papineau sefa lien donc le
seul avec sa peut-être très épaisse la
avoir encore une canine c'était des
herbivores l'état pineau cfa liens et
celle et à pino ses fans ya là la
plupart des tapis non c'est le fallait
non pas de canines toutes leurs dents
sont herbivores
mais lui il conserve encore une canine
bien développés ce qui les représentent
et la voilà donc ça c'est un tapis nos
efforts c'est un tapis nokan innus que
j'ai eu la chance de trouver avec mon
collègue kevin wray que je salue
voilà qu'on a qu'on a trouvé et l'emploi
vous voyez le ça ressemble à un gros
caillou voilà mais nous voilà ce qu'on
voit et c'est exactement ça qui est
représentée ici c'est à dire que là vous
avez le sommet du crâne coupé où on voit
la section du crâne avec la fenêtre
temporal sur le côté on voit à l'oeil
l'oeil est là ce que vous voyez ici
c'est l'oeil et là vous avez la bouche
est ici quand vous regardez vous voyez
les sections des dents et on voit qu'il
ya une section d'une des dents qui est
plus grosse que les autres c'est la
canine donc on sait que cet appui aux
canines us et puis il ya un autre
dinosaure fall qui s'appelle l'australo
sociaux dont qui a inventé
zaur très primitif parce qu'il n'ya pas
du tout de deux paquets hostos du crâne
l'eau ce n'est pas du tout été si par
contre il ya une très très grosse
canning mais pour l'instant il y en a
qu'un seul qui a été trouvée donc niveau
fossiles niveau fossiles stratigraphique
ça se pose là c'est non c'est pas
terrible a évidemment d'avoir un seul
faux cils c'est pas terrible du tout
voilà ta pineau canine us au moins on en
a trouvé 4 les héros dc naudon c'est
vraiment ceux qui sont les plus les plus
abondants dallas trouver peut-être six
ou sept
aujourd'hui on ne trouve pas grand chose
donc c'est pas une zone qui est très
très très très bien défini la zone à
jodie synodaux on est encore en train
d'essayer de comprendre où se trouve la
fin de la zone à us au kiss-in aux dents
est le début de la biozone suivante et
on est même en train de se demander s'il
n'y aurait pas encore une autre bio
jeunes entre les deux en réalité
donc il est possible que la bio que la
zone a et au dc naudon finissent par
avoir une petite soeur très bientôt
mais bon on verra ça on verra ça en
fonction de comment se développent les
recherches dans le futur et la zone a et
audi sinon qu'elle est intéressante
parce qu'on arrive à l'accord est né
avec certaines certaines biozone qui ont
été établis notamment en asie c'est à
dire que pendant très longtemps on
pensait que les plus vieux signale que
les plus vieux terre apside était en
asie est maintenant en fait on arrive à
corréler les naseaux nahio d'ici naudon
avec ses plus vieilles roches qui ont
donné des rapides en asie donc notamment
en chine en chine vous avez si nos faux
nez lui ce qui est un très ancien et
très primitif en teoz hors du même
niveau justement que costral aux cieux
dont l'équivalent russe c'est sûr dont
et en russie vous avez soumis n'y a qu'
à un anneau moudon très primitif
un peu comme patronaux meudon et en
chine vous avez be séries dance qui
comme pat radiothon est un anneau me
donc primitive dans le journal de même
en fait encore une fois c'est des
tentatives de corrélation c'est à dire
que là on est sur les mêmes degré
d'évolution en fait donc l'assemblage
phonique contient des espèces de même
degré d'évolution en chine en russie et
en afrique du sud
et donc on fait l'hypothèse raisonnable
que ces assemblages phonique se sont
formées en même temps et le problème
c'est qu'on a toujours pas d'âge absolue
en afrique du sud
on n'a toujours pas d'âge absolue en
russie et je crois pas qu'ils aient déjà
absolue non plus en chine
donc voilà donc c'est vraiment
l'hypothèse pour l'instant qui est dans
l'air et contestera des concours dès
qu'on pourra faire des datation absolue
maintenant on entre dans une bio zone
qui est un peu plus connu beaucoup mieux
connu en réalité c'est la zone at à
pinos et phallus donc c'est une de ces
bio zones qui ont été établies dès le
début en fait la zone at à pinos et
phallus ou tapis noke phallus
comme on devrait dire puisque ça vient
du grec et quand ça vient du grec le
sait se prononce ce que vous demandez
pas pourquoi alors que la zone a et audi
sino dont elle par contre elle a été
établie en 1995 donc c'est la biozone
qui a été établi le plus récemment la
zone à jodie si nos maux mais là on
entre dans les bio zone historique et en
vidéo la zone à tapis dans quel phallus
c'est aussi du permien moyens donc c'est
une zone c'est une bio zone qui est
qui est aussi du permis à moyens donc la
partie supérieure on va dire du permien
moyens alors que la zone ayo disent non
c'est la partie inférieure du permien
moyens on est à peu près entre 264 et
260 millions d'années et voilà à quoi ça
ressemble la zone à tapis no kill
phallus donc là maintenant les couches
sont horizontales c'est ça que je veux
vous montrer sur cette photo là
maintenant les couches sont horizontales
et avec cette photo je voulais juste
vous donner une impression un peu du
gigantisme des surfaces à explorer quand
on parle de zone est à pino qui ait
fallu c'est la zone la plus c'est la
biozone la plus grande en termes de
surfaces exposées et c'est juste
interminable on a partout essayé aussi
la biozone qui se situe dans la partie
la plus sèche du caroux donc c'est donc
non seulement elle est gigantesque en
termes d'exposition en terme de surface
mais en plus il n'y a pas d'herbe il n'y
a rien qui la recouvre donc vraiment
c'est 100% de l'affleurement quoi
maintenant que c'est vraiment quand vous
arrivez dans la zone un tapis hookés
phallus vous vous demandez par vous
commencez sacrebleu par où je démarre
par où je commence à regarder en réalité
faut regarder des goûts santé de la
voiture qu'on sait exactement ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire là voilà ils sont
à peine sorti de la voiture ils sont
déjà en train de chercher et donc cette
zone at à pinocchio phallus elle est
caractérisée par l'écrasante domination
des dinos et fall donc les dinos effacé
comme le tapis nokan innus et le 6 nov
onu ce que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure ce sont des gros machin avec des
sales têtes qui ont un crâne très très
épais d'une
phénomène qui s'appelle l'apa qui oppose
leur crâne est très très très très très
épais probablement parce que justement
il se battait les uns sur les autres
sauf que là où on en rencontre et comme
j'ai dit on tout on a cinq tapine aux
canines us en tout et on a un nostra nos
cieux donc dans la zone high odissi
redon dans la zone à tapie donc les
phallus vous avez vous en trouvez
quasiment tous les trois mètres vous en
trouvez un morceau au moins tous les
trois mètres du dino ses fans c'est un
truc assez
enfin au moins dans la partie la plus
haute la plus jeune de la zone à tapie
auxquels phallus vous trouvé des restes
de dino céphale absolument partout et
ils sont très reconnaissables
ils sont très abondants et ils sont très
reconnaissables parce que c'est des gros
mots c'est pas qui est aux tic justement
ces cdo qui sont extrêmement robuste et
serait extrêmement et paix sur tous les
tapis noces et fall qui ont un squelette
qui est aussi patriotique donc même le
squelette et baraquin font donc donc cdo
qui sont extrêmement identifiable ne
juste par leur simple épaisseur quoi en
fait
donc rien que ça ça vous indique
immédiatement bon ben ok vous êtes dans
la zone à tapie n'en s'est fallu donc au
moins dans la partie supérieure de la
tapie n'en s'est fallu s' la partie la
plus jeune vous trouvé énormément de
sedin au cefral dans la partie
inférieure c'est moins vrai c'est moins
vrai c'est un peu plus compliqué de
trouver des bas parce qu'on sort de la
zone à jodie synodaux que et que dans la
zone a et auditionnera on trouvait déjà
pas grand chose donc au début de la zone
à tapie n'en s'est fallu ce ça reste un
peu la même tendance peut-être on était
encore trop près du pôle info voir que
pendant tout le temps qu'on va traverser
la fois voir que pendant tout le permis
à moyen supérieur jeu trias ses débuts
jurassique là toute cette période qu'on
va traverser pendant notre traversée du
caroux l'afrique s'éloigne de plus en
plus du pôle
voilà donc alors que l'afrique s'éloigne
du pôle et ben du coup le c'est plus
facile pour les faune terrestre
notamment de s'établir sur dans le chaos
donc il est possible que ce soit un
gradient en fait d'abondance qui soit
essentiellement dus à la
au fait que l'afrique s'éloigne de plus
en plus du pôle bon c'est une hypothèse
comme une autre donc voilà donc on à
tapis noté phallus most shops le
probablement le plus connu de ces dino
ses fans most shops qui est très
reconnaissable donc mots stop c'est à
pinos et le phallus et tous les dinos
cfa liens qui sont très reconnaissables
à la morphologie de leurs dents donc
même si vous trouvez dans isolé vous
savez que saadi nos ses fans tout
simplement parce que cette forme là il
ya c'est ce qu'on appelle en anglais le
talonne à nerim morphologie donc
lasserre le talonne comme les comme les
oiseaux lasserre et le le bassin en fête
est en fait les dents sans boiter comme
ça pour créer des surfaces d'attrition
pour mâcher la nourriture végétale parce
que ce sont des végétariens l'état
pineau c'est validé donc ça c'est ça
c'est très très typique des dinos et
fall herbivores d'avoir cette formation
talonnade et fils avec donc le pilon en
fait ouais c'est on devrait dire ça en
français le pilon et le le nom c'est le
mortier le pilon c'est ça le mortier et
le pilon et donc vous avez les mortiers
l'épilogué comme ça se succèdent les
unes derrière les autres
ça se voit bien là sur le crâne du most
shops ici les incisives notamment ont
bien cette morphologie en mortier pilon
et puis vous avez quelques carnivores
aussi donc qui que sont les hanter aux
orres très reconnaissables à leurs
immenses canine et à leur grande et à
leur incisive qui se croisent comme ça
et ça c'est rien et on les retrouve
ailleurs que en afrique du sud
et ça permet aussi du coup de faire des
corrélations encore une fois avec la
russie estime hainaut sus très connu
pour ses grandes cornes assez dindinaud
céphale donc la biozone a estimé nos sus
de russie elle est corrélée avec celles
d'afrique du sud encore une fois pas de
date en russie donc on n'est pas sûr
mais l'hypothèse raisonnable et que
c'est du père bien moyen terminal comme
en afrique du sud
et puis pareil on n'a pas de date pour
ces roches au brésil mais on a inventé
aux orres qui a été découvert au brésil
et qui permet de dire encore une fois
que qui permet de faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable que ces roches sont aussi du
permis aux moyens au brésil et sachant
qu'avant d'avoir découvert cette en teoz
or il était persuadé de ne pas avoir du
tout permis un moyen en tout cas pas
continental et ben ça ça représente
quelque chose quand même 7 cette
découverte
alors maintenant la zone à tapie nous
quelle phallus elle est divisée en deux
biozone avant de passer aux deux bureaux
zone on va juste je vais trop vite en
besogne je vais trop vite on trouve pas
que des dinos et fall pardon dans la
zone à tapis de ces phallus on trouve
aussi des gros terreau céphale donc qui
avec les hanter aux orres jouait le rôle
des carnivores dominant on n'a pas
encore de gore bonne observance du moins
avec le peu de grands bonhommes siècle
on à son tout petit et pas vraiment très
pas vraiment très significatif d'un
point de vue écologique
on a très peu de gorgone obtient à
l'époque les gros prédateur dominant de
l'époque se sont pas les gorgones
obtient ce sont les gros terreau céphale
et les hanter aux ors et les herbivores
dominants sont les tapis nos seifalian
ce ne sont pas encore lady synodaux donc
les 10 et 90 sont encore relativement
rare et le plus abondant d'entre eux c
est aussi moche ce qui est très très
proche morphologiquement on va dire de
héros dc nos dons à part que les primes
axillaires maintenance ont fusionné quoi
si vous regardez voyez
prix maxi d'air on ne voit plus de
suture au niveau du prêt maxillaire on a
aussi l'apparition de la première
apparition des parias zor et alors là
des parias gens c'est un grand mystère
on n'a aucune idée de louis sorte que ce
soit en russie ou en afrique du sud
d'ailleurs ils apparaissent comme ça de
nulle part on sait pas d'où ils sortent
c'est jusque là seul coup beaumont à
brady zaurus voilà qui apparaît donc les
pareil hasard sont intéressants aussi
niveau bio stratigraphique puisque dans
le permis à moyens ils sont gros et ils
n'ont qu'une seule rangée de ce thé au
derme sur la colonne vertébrale ou deux
ou trois mais en tout cas ils ont pas
trop de ils ont un nombre très limité
d'ostéo derme qui suit la colonne
vertébrale
alors que dans le père bien supérieur
les parts et azor vont avoir tendance à
devenir beaucoup plus petit sauf par
raya zaurus sauf pareil à zaurus escutes
aux russes c'est dommage c'est de plus
connu les deux plus connus sont
évidemment les contre exemples mais
n'ont en général les pareil hasard du
père bien supérieures sont petits ils
deviennent petits et leur corps est
complètement recouvert de sté moderne
brady est pareil à sorrus escutes aux
eaux russes sont assez typique de ce
point de vue là ils sont recouverts
complètement d'ostéo dame
donc on les distingue quand même on
arrive quand même à les distinguer du
coût des pareils azor du père bien un
moyen du permis and the data pinos et
phallus mai mais par contre ils sont
atypiques dans le sens où ils sont trop
gros en fait normalement les pins enfin
la moyenne générale des paris à bord du
père bien supérieur ils sont plutôt de
taille moyenne à petit donc de la taille
d'une grosse tortue grand maximum quoi
et donc maintenant la zone à tapie n'en
s'est fallu sel est divisé en deux zones
donc c'est est-ce assez c'est
un des grands progrès qu'il ya eu sur la
division bio stratigraphique qui a eu
avant 2020 en fait avant 2020 la zone à
tapis de cefalu s'il n'y avait qu'une
seule zone
maintenant on est capable de la diviser
en deux la diviser en deux zones la zone
est en fait la différence entre ces deux
zones c'est l'apparition d'un dc 90 qui
s'appelle dicton dont le fameux dicton
donc si vous avez vu les vidéos de
cédric vous savez que dicte aux dons
c'est le lapin de garenne du permien le
lapin de garenne du permis en trouve
partout on trouve partout il y en a
partout tout le temps voilà bon ben en
fait c'est pas partout tout le temps
c'est surtout surtout sur la fin du
mieux du permien moyens et le début du
père bien supérieur en fait donc c'est
une période de crise biologique fin du
permien moyens début du pernois
supérieur de crise biologique qu'on
appelle la crise du capital y un an fin
ou la crise de la fin du gwada l'obtient
et donc cette crise biologique et baal a
beaucoup profité à ce petit herbivores
qui s'appelle dicte aux dents et 10
octobre dont il est très facile à
identifier parce que c'est contrairement
à est aussi moche ce le sa boîte
crânienne est très étroite
donc il ya une région intertemporelle
qui est relativement étroite alors que
vraiment chez aussi mops la zone de la
boîte crânienne est très large
ça se reflète pas du tout en termes de
taille de cerveau c'est juste fonction
de la taille des muscles en fait c'est
pas du tout à une histoire de taille de
cerveau c'est juste une histoire de
taille des muscles masticatoire d'odile
taux dont avait des plus grands muscles
mastic à tort que aussi mops du coup ça
qu'on pressent plus la boîte crânienne
au sommet du crâne et dicte aux dons est
très reconnaissable aussi à cet angle
droit entre son processus quasi uniforme
ici et son bec
là il ya un angle droit extrêmement
prononcée donc à 90 degrés est ce assez
et ça même avec beaucoup de déformation
voit quand même en fait donc dicté aux
dons est très très très reconnaissable
grâce à ça et donc la différence entre
les deux sous-zones en fait c'est que la
zone là sous zone inférieure n'a pas de
dictons alors que la soude zone
supérieure a dicté dans les deux zones
dont on leur a donné des noms en face et
la convention seller convention bio
stratigraphique qui veulent que les
zones les biozone ont un nom simple par
contre les sous zones doivent avoir un
nom un binôme en fait donc un binôme de
deux sous-espèces et du coup ça donne ça
donne des choses assez assez ridicule
fond d'une assez ridiculeusement
compliqué alala sous-zones addict aux
deux tirs à coke et phallus mais surtout
ça vous donne des sous zones avec des
taxons qui sont pas spécialement hyper
représentatif parce que la susanna est
aussi moffs ici donc la soudaine
inférieures cette zone a est aussi moche
ce n'est pas caractérisée par la
présence d oc mops puisque est aussi
mops on le trouve aussi dans la sous-
zone supérieure en fait donc mais le
problème c'est qu'il fallait
voilà ce que ce que m'ont dit les gens
qui ont donné des noms assez soudaine à
savoir bruce rue viger michael bay donc
professeur bruce rue viger docteur
michael bay sont pas des random quand
même parce qu'ils m'ont dit c'est que
bah y'a pas à dire il ya pas il n'y a
pas une faune
il n'ya pas munitions illimitées de noms
possibles à donner le dire la faune est
quand même assez limité et le problème
c'est que ben il fallait qu'il faut leur
donner un nom assez sous-zones est
tranquillement dit bah on a pris les
deux fossiles les plus abondants et puis
on les a collés ensemble et voilà quoi
donc bien le problème c'est qu'on a là
sous-zones maintenant qui est la seconde
année aussi mozilla d'hossus cus alors
que est aussi mox et de la noce cus se
retrouve aussi dans la zone supérieure
donc la seule différence entre les deux
sous-zones c'est bel et bien la présence
de dick tôt dans la saison 2 supérieur
estirac ok phallus alors ce tir à
coquelles fallu s'il est effectivement
présent uniquement dans la soude
supérieur c'est le dino ses fans que
vous
ici en dessous qui a cette particularité
de beaucoup ressembler à un but on était
amorphe avec sa bosse sur l'oeil et sa
bosse sur le score nozal ici alors
stéréo qu'il fallut s'il est loin d'être
abonde en quoi c'est pas impossible que
je qualifierais de suffisamment
abondante pour faire un bon pour faire
un bon fossiles index colombo fossiles
stratigraphique mais bref et donc on ad
âge là pour le coup on ad âge un peu
plus solide de séparation entre ces deux
sous zones donc la séparation entre les
deux sous zones ses 262 millions
d'années et donc la zone at à pinos et
phallus s'arrête à 260 millions d'années
quand on rentre dans la zone suivante la
zone a en d'autres sur donc qui est la
zone représentait en bleu ici on voyait
ici tout ça en jaune c'était la zone à
tapie n'en s'est fallu s' nous avons
traversé mais revel nous sommes arrivés
désormais à bout forte ouest
beauportoise qui marque le début de la
zone allant de tueur dont et donc
l'entrée dans le père bien supérieur le
père bien j'ai envie de dire le plus
typique du carbon quand quand vous
entendez parler du permien du caroux
rarement vous entendez parler des dinos
et fall mais par contre vous entendez
parler des dix innovantes et les dix
innovante c'est le père bien supérieur
être intervient et le trias donc voilà à
quoi ressemble la zone d'un monde aux
tuyaux de canton quand on y va donc la
zone avant tokyo dans cette façon c'est
comme tout le reste du caroux j'ai envie
de dire c'est une alternance marno
gréseuses ceci dit la zone allant de
tueur dont a cela de particulier qu'elle
que son début en fête est marquée par
cet énorme couche degré jaunâtre que
vous voyez là et cet énorme de créer
deux couches degré jaunâtre ll est
vraiment très très marqué dans le dans
le paysage on la voit assez facilement
en fait même de loin et ça s'appelle le
donc c'est sandton en anglais legré ça
se dit sandton c'est même plus simple
d'ailleurs en anglais parce que le grèce
et de la roche fait de sable un dur et
en anglais samb stones voilà la vie en
anglais est tellement plus simple je
comprends pas pourquoi le français c'est
si compliqué regardez en français vous
avez le fruit de la pomme et l'arbre on
appelle ça le pommier pourquoi on a
inventé un mot nouveau alors qu'en
français alors qu'en anglais vous avez
le fruit apple est là où apple tree
l'arbre à bonn c'est quand même
vachement plus simple voilà c'est pareil
vous avez le sable vous avez la roche
sandstone bref je m'égare donc cette
cette couche de roche
cette couche degrés donc très épaisse et
très très jaune alors que vous voyez le
reste est un peu légèrement rouge
pourpre bleuâtre ou gris alors je vous
avoue que moi et les couleurs non mais
pas pote surtout dans surtout quand il
s'agit des couleurs géologique vous
savez que les couleurs géologique afin
peut-être vous savez peut-être vous
savez pas mais les couleurs en géologie
en fait c'est très important
c'est très important et je suis
extrêmement mauvaise je la vois là c'est
surtout là où je veux en venir
les roches en géologie vous avez des
petits livres ils vendent des petits
livres avec des chartes de couleurs et
ses chars de couleurs il ya un petit
trou à côté de la couleur et en fait
vous êtes censé mettre le petit trou sur
la roche et voir si ça match la couleur
et chaque couleur un code-barres et donc
vous êtes censé désigner la couleur des
roches en fonction de ce code barre et
moi je suis à chier il y en a qui est
moi je regarde une roche je faisais les
violettes et puis non là qui mêle le tri
prend son truc de géo
le col saint-georges effet 96 rouge à
merde ça s'écrit perdu ses marrons bon
là au moins on est d'accord sur sept sur
sept couches degré là moi je la vois
jaunes et les géologues la voit jaune
aussi est donc cette couche d'or jaune
s'appelle le pôle qui donc paul qui en
afrikaans ça veut dire ça veut dire
chaudron c'est là donc c'est là le gré
du chaudron je ne sais pas pourquoi
cette tranche du pôle qui elle est
vraiment très très mince est secret du
pou qui est vraiment très très facile à
voir dans le paysage en fait ben là
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris cette photo
parce que voyez malgré encore une fois
l'immensité des des surfaces à explorer
et là encore il ya qu une montagne ben
vous voyez que tout de suite on sait
qu'on est en train de regarder le pool
qui alors il ya des fois il ya quand
même un cas où la roche du pool qui
n'avait pas l'air d'être corrélée à la
zone en audio dont donc il ya quand même
une fois où là ça marche pas c'est quand
même un endroit dans le cas où ça ne
marche pas ce qui fait se poser la
question du coût de la synchronicité du
bouquet ou bien de la synchronicité des
débit aux zones mais bon ça c'est du
détail mais il faut on va pas rentrer là
dedans tout de suite donc et cette zone
donc cette zone du pool qui en fait
elles correspondent du copil voyez ici
hop le pool qui s'est écrit là alors
poule qui sas équipe ça s'écrit porte j
oui c'est une langue bizarre la
fréquentent donc porte j en fais tu ici
ça veut dire ça se dit poule qui et
c'est la fameuse roche dont je vous
parle c'est la fameuse couche degré dont
je vous parle donc ça ça correspond à la
crise capital yens crise de la fin du
capitanat où la crise de la fin du gwada
loupien c'est la même chose c'est la
crise de l'acquis marque la fin du
permien moyens et le début du permien
supérieur et donc cette crise elle est
marquée par notamment l'extinction des
dinos et fall et le l'avènement j'ai
envie de dire de dicte aux dons
le dicte au don devient l'espèce enfin
le genre dominant de tous les
assemblages fossiles à cette époque et
donc dicton je le rappelle c'est ce
petit gars là avec son petit angle à 90°
là haut niveau 2 dubec petits petits
fans fact la zone arrondo tuyaux dont
s'appelait autrefois la zone a pris ce
terreau ignatus donc vous voyez là le
pool qui est ici est donc autrefois elle
s'appelait la zone a pris cette héroïne
hiatus sauf qu'on s'est rendu compte
enfin docteur michael bay s'est rendu
compte en fait que priest et natus donc
le terreau ses fans qui donnait son nom
à la zone d'assemblage en fait quand on
regarde la distribution bio
stratigraphique de prix stéroïdes hiatus
ici là c'est pointillés c'est là où
commence le pool qui est en fait précis
théorie natus c'est un bien longtemps
avant le pouls qui donc en fait la zone
a pris stéroïdes hiatus n'avait aucun
priester onatus c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que si vous regardez
éventuellement de la vieille littérature
vous risquez de voir la zone d'un prix
starhawk natus dans la littérature mais
en fait il y avait zéro pour hystérie
natus dans cette zone
donc il a fallu changer son nom en
évidemment donc la zone aventure donc
dans lequel date de deux cents soit elle
commence à 260 millions d'années elle se
termine à 257 millions d'années donc
elle fait trois millions d'années
elle est évidemment caractérisée par la
présence dans d'autres eaux dont qui est
le premier gros d'ici nous donc à
exister en dur dont les crânes sont gros
comme ça voilà gran adultes dans
d'autres non c'est gros comme ça donc
c'est du beau jeu les bonnes bases voyez
soissons il ya une échelle ici devant
vous donc c'est donc il n'ya pas de ya
pas de doute à avoir sur la taille du
crâne dans l'eau sur yon celle des
premiers gros d'ici nous donne donc
c'est les premiers 10 lots dont en fait
à marquer l'avènement on va dire des dc
90 ans quand en tant qu'art vivent en
dominant l'état pineau ses fans se sont
éteints l'état pineau sefa liens se sont
éteints et ont été remplacés maintenant
parler d'ici 90 et en totu redon et le
premier d'entre eux en voiture dont il
est quand même loin d'être un
dc nos danses typiques puisque comme
vous le voyez il n'a pas de défense et
il a beaucoup de dents donc il avait
avec quand même vous voyez que là il ya
quand même une bonne morphologie de bec
une bonne morphologie de perroquets ou
de tricératops
mais malgré ce dès qu ils n'avaient pas
les défenses et il a plein dedans
et alors c'est dans en plus elles sont
organisées en batterie donc il est
vraiment très très loin d'être le dis si
nos deux typique c'est à peu près c'est
pas le seul d'ici 90 qui a sa des
batteries de dents ou pas deux ou pas de
défense mais enfin c'est le seul qui
conjugue quand même la combinaison la
combinaison grosse taille batterie
dentaire plus pas de défense donc il est
très très reconnaissable plus il a des
petites bosses un peu partout sur le
crâne mais il n'y a pas une gueule de
porte bonheur en fait en deux turbos
mais du coup ça rend très reconnaissable
donc très intéressant pour nous et il
est très abondant il est relativement
abondant est-ce qui va marquer aussi le
fait qu'on entre dans la zone arrondo
tueur dans ça va devenir l'extrême
abondance de dick taux dont je vous ai
dit tu donc commence à devenir déjà
abondant à la fin de la zone à pinos et
phallus dans la zone à endosser aux dons
ça en devient quasiment grotesque et je
ne peux pas assister suffisamment sûres
à quel point ça devient grotesque en
fait c'est à dire que vous voyez un os
c'est à dire vous
j'avais pris une photo à une époque je
n'ai pas remis cela dans mon course
c'est dommage mais j'avais pris une
photo et une époque où j'avais trouvé la
crainte de dict dont je m'étais dit
chouette un crâne de dictons je me suis
assis j'ai levé les yeux il y avait
littéralement une distance de marteau de
géologues plus loin ça fait trente
centimètres une distance de marteau de
géologues plus loin il y avait un autre
crâne de dictons et je ne parle pas d'un
os de dictons je parle il y avait un
crâne complet de dictons et une distance
de marteau de géologues plus loin il y
avait un autre crâne complet de 10,8 au
dos et vous aviez un horizon comme ça
qu'ils étaient farci de crâne
ils t'ont de crâne de ce que l'aide tout
ce que vous voulez il y en avait partout
et si vous vous mettiez vraiment à
quatre pattes commencé à regarder par
terre traiterait de façon très précise
là vous vous rendiez compte qu'il y
avait des jo mais partout partout
partout partout et très souvent des becs
débecte dit aux dons qui sont du coup
très reconnaissable parce qu'ils ont cet
angle droit et c'est ça valait vraiment
ça en devient grotesque en fait donc là
j'ai marqué extrême abondance de dictons
mais je devrai marqué avons une
abondance ou est ridicule
en anglais on dirait où les 10 kg où
l'abondance à ce niveau là c'est
ridicule ça veut pas dire la même chose
en anglais qu'en français ça veut pas
dire c'est juste ouais ça en devient
comique un certain niveau vous vous
revenez je me rappelle avoir fait une
journée où je on a ramené enfin moi même
j'avais ramené je crois 25 crade de
dictons et rien d'autre c'est à dire
vous trouvez rien d'autre que des crânes
le dicton partout tout le temps c'est ça
devient bon bref c'est très bien pour
les débutants la zone allant de kyoto
pour emmener les débutants c'est parfait
c'est parfait c'est le meilleur endroit
du monde parce que vous n'êtes jamais
déçu quoi vous trouvez tout le temps
quelque chose mais bon ce sera du dicton
là où ça devient là ça devient sportif
justement c'est de commencer à ignorer
les dicte aux dons et à commencer à
trouver autre chose mais bon on doit la
après ça se pose la question éthique du
doit-on ignoré des données fossiles
doit-on ignorer j'ai envie de dire
volontairement certains beauzile bomba
bref c'est une autre question est donc
cette zone arrondo tueur donc pareil à
n'était pas divisé avant enfin si elles
étaient historiquement elle a été
divisée mais en fait comme
ouais mon bras c'est pas la peine de
partir dans la zone sepa partir c'est
pas la peine de partir dans l'histoire
du réseau d'un lucho dont la zone nord
nature on est divisé en deux zones
même si ça n'a pas été historiquement le
cas où que c'est compliqué mais bref
elle est divisée en deux zones pareil on
a une idée relative de durée de chaque
zone
la première dure 2 millions d'années la
deuxième dur un million d'années
donc vous voyez quand même qu'on arrive
à descendre sur une précision d'un
million d'années ce qui est pas
dégueulasse avec des vertébrés
je sais que s'il ya des gens qui
travaillent avec des ammonites vous êtes
des bleus mais je sais je sais je sais
les gens qui travaillent avec des
ammonites dans le mésozoïque se marre à
l'idée d'entendre qu'on a des bio zone
relativement correct à un million
d'années
sachant que il arrive à descendre
jusqu'à je sais plus et 200000 ou vingt
mille ans je ne sais plus dans les
commentaires faites le moi savoir s'il y
a des s'il ya des ammonites hologue si
calme il doit savoir tient pas les world
cicad
si tu me regardes en ce moment peux tu
nous dire jusqu'à combien on peut
descendre avec des ammonites il me
semble que ces vingt mille ans il arrive
à descendre sur des intervalles de vingt
mille ans avec les ammonites nous avec
nos petits enfin on n'a pas de bio zone
qui descendent jusqu'à vingt mille ans
mais je sais que dans la zone permien
trias qui est très très très très bien
étudié donc à la transition en fait
entre le permien trias on a quand même
une précision à 25 mille ans on arrive
quand même à descendre à une résolution
qui vingt à vingt-cinq mille ans avec
notre système de bio zonation en
regardant les extinctions et tout ça qui
est est un qui est encore là qui va
changer tout ça on descend sur une
précision de l'ordre de 25 mille ans
mais c'est le mieux qu'on puisse faire
quoi et c'est parce que ça a été sûr
étudié au niveau de la limite permise
trias mais la voilà vous aurez pas une
pio zone meilleur qu'un million d'années
dans le chaos bref est donc la
différence entre les deux biozone donc
bon bah déjà les deux biozone en fait
non plus de dino céphale du conte est
maintenant dans le permis
et rieur mais par contre ce qu'il ya
c'est que la biozone inférieur va avoir
une faune qui est en gros la même que
celle de la zone à tapie n'en s'est
fallu s' - les dinos et fall donc c'est
ce qui est écrit ici en fait c'est
exactement la même faune que dans la
zone at à pinos et phallus les dinos ses
fans en moins alors que dans la zone
supérieure
vous allez avoir addition de choses
qu'il n'y avait pas dans la zone à tapis
de cefalu donc en fait la zone de la
zone en d'autres chaudron inférieur
c'est la zone à tapis naucelle phallus
avec beaucoup dicte aux dons de landau
kyodo et voilà donc c'est vraiment la
biozone de crise j'ai presque envie de
dire c'est vraiment la biozone qui
reflète le qui reflète le mieux le fait
que la faune est en crise c'est à dire
que vous avez très peu de l'addition de
nouveaux taxons par dessus ce qui s'est
éteint dans la zone at à pinos et
phallus en faut un par an de tubes dont
il ya quarante autres chiots d'eau qui
est réellement nouveau dans cette zone
est par contre dans la zone supérieure
donc la zone atrophie dos tomas gorgodze
pas vous avez justement l'arrivée de
tromper dos thomas qui est ce dissident
ici qui est très très reconnaissable à
sa forme de coeur très très prononcé
tous les dissidents dont un crâne qui
est plus ou moins en forme de coeur
quand on les regarde vue du dessus mais
trophy dos thomas il va vraiment cette
forme là vraiment cette forme et si
jamais vous avez le moindre doute sur le
fait que c'est un trophy dos thomas
tropicale tomas
c'est un dc 90 qui a 2 crée de sagittale
normalement vous n'avez qu'une seule
crainte sagittale au sommet du crâne
luisant à deux donc c'est si jamais vous
avez moindre doute sur le fait que c'est
un profit de ce tome à vous pouvez
regarder le nombre de crédits sagittale
s'il y en a deux c'est trophy dos thomas
mais là vraiment où est cette forme de
coeur très très très très très typique
beaucoup plus prononcé que chez
n'importe quel autre d'ici 90 et vous
avez l'arrivée de gorgone up c'est donc
avec lui des gorgones obtient donc dans
la zone à partir de la zone supérieure à
en d'auteurs dont en fait vous allez
commencer à avoir les gorgones obtient
qui vont devenir les prédateurs dominant
alors que dans la sous- zone
la plus basse de la zone hors d'eau sur
dans celle là les teros efa lien les
gros terreau sefa liens sont toujours
les prédateurs dominant donc là on
commence à avoir une faune qui prend un
cachet en fait avec cette zone
supérieure cette zone a trop peu de sel
sous-zones un trophy dos tomas gorgodze
en fait vous allez avoir la faune qui
prendre son cachet père bien supérieur
définitif là on lui de dire ça devient
du vrai beau père bien supérieur voilà
avec des gorgones obtient qui deviennent
des prédateurs dominant donc là le père
bien supérieur très typique et donc
pareil on peut corréler le sud africain
avec d'autres couches qui est qu'ils ont
d'autres couches ailleurs dans le monde
par exemple en inde
ils ont découvert un don de dieu donc
donc pareil il ya corrélation entre les
couches en inde et en afrique du sud la
zone à qui ce teckel phallus qui est la
zone suivante donc là on était à
beaufort tout est ici nous avons
traversé toute la zone a rang d'option
dont nous suivons la route principale
entre le cap et johannesbourg et nous
arrivons à murray ce bug ici est alors
un mail ce bug alors c'est pour vous
montrer
l'année dernière avec nous il ya deux
ans maintenant avec séverine jurassique
nous étions ici au tour de victoria
ouest donc nous avons regardé des
couches qui était de la zone at à pinos
et phallus et de la zona ans de turbans
donc la photo que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure avec le bout qui s'étaient
quand cédric était là donc on était
vraiment sur cette limite parfaitement
ici quand cette photo a été prise donc
maintenant là on s'éloigne un peu de
tout ça on arrive à merris bug dans la
zone à qui ce téké phallus et qui
s'était kéfa luce vous oui avant donc on
parle de crise tech et phallus voici à
quoi ressemble la zone à qui ce téké
phallus c'est le carouge a envie de dire
le plus typique c'est le quart ou des
cartes postales en face et si vous avez
vous avez déjà reçu une carte postale du
carreau évidemment
j'ai envie de dire c'est le carreau de
carte postale c'est le beau qu'à rouler
voyez cette alternance marne ou gazeuse
magnifique les collines la végétation
relativement belle parce qu on est sorti
du caroux très très sec le carreau de la
zone à tapis de cefalu c'est le caroux
très très sec et on est rentrés
maintenant dans un car ou un petit
peuple verdoyant mais toujours à vous
voyez avec des bots affleurements et
vous avez ces collines
voilà les fameuses collines très typique
du caroux avec le sommet plat et puis
les pentes comme ça bien défini et vous
voyez ces affleurements sas a fait baver
quoi c'est pour ça que j'appelle ça de
40 cartes postales quoi ça fait baver
des affleurements comme ça c'est leur
aile du palais autonome de voir des
choses pareilles c'est moi qui l'ait
pris cette photo donc gillette r oui
mais une chose à dire vrai c'est que les
la zone à qui ce teckel phallus niveau
géologique elle elle coïncide avec ce
qu'on appelle le haut ou de bugs member
of the wolf reformation
le ski est un moyen très compliqué de
dire que vous voyez ici là les vous avez
un assemblage de une deux et trois 3
couches degré là c'est ce qu'on appelle
le ou de bergues member en fait ces
trois couches de vela les triple couche
degrés c'est la zone à kyste et qu'il
fallut voilà c'est ça que ça veut dire
et donc là maintenant on est dans du
permis un moyen très très très très
typique datée d'environ 256 millions
d'années parce que le problème de la
zone a critiqué phallus c'est qu'on n'a
pas de
on a pas de date au sommet et en bas de
la zone à kyste est qu'il fallut par
contre on a une date qui en plein milieu
et donc ses 256 millions d'années donc
on sait que c'est au tour de 256
millions d'années mais on sait pas
exactement combien de temps elle dure là
la zone acquise tech et phallus et donc
elle est caractérisée par la présence de
keith tech il fallut sa médicinaux donc
préféré à vous voyez j'ai pas résister à
l envie de vous montrer mon premier kiss
tech et phallus voilà c'était mon
premier c'est le premier que j'ai trouvé
c'était celui là vous voyez c'est mes
doigts l'avant les reconnaît on y
reconnaît pas s'ils sont des doigts
mais bref c'est mon premier qui sait
quel phallus qui n'étaient pas en fait
mon premier qui s'était qu'il fallut
j'en avais trouvé un juste avant mais à
l'époque j'ai cru que c'était un dicton
donc donc du coup pour moi dans mon
coeur c'est celui là qui est mon premier
qui s'était qu'il fallut et donc qui
sait qu'il fallut c'est très
identifiable par bah c'est son nom qui
se tait qu'il fallut state de boîte
c'est exactement ce que ça veut dire
parce que ça à tête forme une boîte
voilà ce gros truc rectangulaire là
derrière ces yeux là ça c'est typique de
kyste est qu'il fallut c'est vous voyez
ça se voit très bien sur les fossiles
c'est ce qu'on appelle à une région
intertemporelle très très large c'est la
condition la plus opposée que vous
puissiez avoir à la présence d'une crête
sagittale donc sa salle caractérise qui
s'était phallus petite tête en forme de
boîte très typique un autre fossile très
commun de la zone à qui ce teckel
phallus c'est au lac et falot donne aux
laquelle falot donne qui est un gros
d'ici 90 aussi donc toujours maintenant
on est dans la la domination écologie
des dc nodong donc maintenant on aura
des gros dicillo d'onde contrairement au
bio zones précédentes ou en deux
tiendront était le seul gros d'ici 90
laon maintenant on est dans la zone
artistique est fallut donc on a du
grandissime vente et au lac il fallait
donner tagro 10 90 qui est la
particularité d'avoir deux grosses
bosses sur le nez il a un petit cousin
qui s'appelle pelle à nos maux dont qui
lui ressemble un peu mais hélas nos
modèles plus petits donc au lac et le
falot donnent ils à ces deux grosses
bosses sur le nez qui permettent de
l'identifier assez facilement et on
constate du coup maintenant
maintenant que la crise est derrière
nous maintenant que la crise du
guadeloupéen est derrière nous et bien
le dicton qui est ce disaster saxon
commence à décroître et est remplacé par
un nouveau d'ici 90 aussi de taille
moyenne à gross qui s'appelle ou des
nous donne ou des nous donne qui est un
kyste etc et phallus - les défenses en
gros et qui n'a pas évidemment le
l'angle droit
du processus canine effort et vous allez
commencer à avoir les gros gorgone
obtient notamment les rubis jean dées
les fameux rugby jean qui sont les
énormes gorgone obtient très typique
alors le problème le problème c'est que
quand on vous représentent des gros
cargos n'obtient notamment si vous
regardez les reportage de la bbc les
gros gorgone obtient qu'on vous
représente généralement c'est i nostri
chez via qui est un gorgone obtient de
russie qui est très très gros mais qui
n'est pas arrivé jean donc j'ai bien
envie de vous dire les gros cargos
n'obtient qu'on vous représente dans les
films ce sont des rubis jean mais c'est
pas vrai en fait les généralement les
gros cargos n'obtient qu'on vous
représente partout c'est in austen chez
via une hotline chez via in austen chez
via n'est pas un rugby jean
c'est une grosse convergence évolutive
en fait innocent match evian c'est une
histoire intéressante aussi mais c'est
une convergence évolutive avec les rubis
jean donc non les rubis jeans et dino
gorgone ce miley cyrus
rubis jane trucks le plus gros d'entre
tous le crâne c'est un hippopotame je
suis j'ai une vidéo sur la connexion rue
beach où justement rubis jane trucks se
trouve donc si vous voulez voir des
crânes de borgo n'obtient qui datent de
la zone à qui ce teckel phallus voilà
c'est cette vidéo là qu'il faut aller
voir donc je vous la mettrait en
description si j'y pense faut que je
pense à mettre la vidéo si j'ai si j'ai
oublié signaler dans les commentaires
j'ai pas trouvé la vidéo sur rubis jane
donc voila et la zone à qui ce teckel
phallus c'est pareil on la trouve pas
que en afrique du sud puis ceux qui
stockent qui sait qu'il fallut ça des
petits cousins en zambie donc qu'à louis
gazeau russe et en inde par exemple le
sort aux capteurs mais toujours avec 7 7
boîte on va dire cette forme de boîte
très typiques comme on la retrouve chez
qui c'était qu'il fallait et on termine
avec le père bien et je pense que ce
sera la dernière biozone pour
aujourd'hui
on termine avec le père bien avec la
zone adapte aux quais phallus la zone
adapte aux quais phallus c'est c'est la
première biozone on va dire qu'il forme
un cercle autour de du lesotho
donc voyez ici la zone adeptes qu'il
fallut sel et là tout autour ne vous
laissez pas duper par le fait qu'elle a
l'air très très vaste
en fait la zone adapte auquel phallus
faut vous imaginer que ici c'est tout
plat donc ici c'est comme le poitou en
fait un pour trouver des affleurements
c'est pas évident ici c'est le kwazulu
natal
donc c'est tropicale donc c'est couvert
de végétation est ici ces listes en cake
il pleut tout le temps c'est pas
tropicale s'est pas mais il pleut tout
le temps donc c'est pareil c'est très
très vert donc en fait le seul endroit
où il ya réellement des dépôts aux
affleurements c'est par là c'est au sud
de bloemfontein passé à peu près entre
bloemfontein et goldberg
c'est là où vous allez trouver les
meilleurs affleurements de la zone
adapte aux quais phallus puis je vous
rappelle que c'est dans ce coin là aussi
qu'elle est le plus profond d'eux enfin
qui avait le plus épaisse du coup la
zone adapte au kiel phallus là aussi
entre cold bergueira frais nets dans ce
coin là vous allez avoir aussi des jeux
10 affleurements notamment du côté de
kaffrine est donc d'employer ne vous
laissez pas ne vous laissez pas duper
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure là
que la zone d'un tapis hookés phallus
était la plus grande en surface c'est
que ici vous avez une surface efficace
en fait j'ai envie de dire c'est
quasiment que de l'affleurement ici vous
avez une grande surface oui mais alors
pour trouver des affleurements mama mama
membres c'est pas évident donc voilà
en surface efficace la zone adapte aux
qu'il fallut c'est beaucoup plus petite
que la zone à tapie donc il fallait mais
bref on continue notre voyage donc on
vient de quitter mu risberg et on entre
voilà sur la route
en fait entre goldberg guérin frais net
et on remonte ici vers bloemfontein dans
la zone adapte aux quais phallus et
cette zone adapte au kiel phallus c'est
la dernière biozone du permien et dans
la littérature vous allez abondamment la
trouvait sous le terme la zone a dit si
nos donne d'ici l'automne qui n'est
alors c'est toujours un taxon valide
d'ici noden mais en fait au tout début
dabo qui ait fallu s'est dit si nous
donne était séparé puis il ya quelqu'un
qui est venu et qui a dit que c'est la
même chose
donc il a fusionné tout andy sino donne
et il ya quelqu'un qui est revenu en
2011 et qui a dit mais non tu dis
n'importe quoi c'est pas la même chose
et qui a re séparer d'ici nous donne et
d'appliquer fallu donc d'acte ok phallus
est revenu en 2011 mais donc il ya une
part très importante de la littérature
qui appellent la zone addict o'keefe qui
appellent la zone adapte au kiel phallus
la zone a dit si nos donne de telle
sorte que même moi je suis pas sûr que
pendant cette présentation que je vous
donne là maintenant si ça se trouve même
moi je vais l'appeler la zone a dit si
nous donne donc bon bref et la zone
adapte aux quais fallu ce ballet juste
juste au dessus en fait de la zone à
kyste et qu'il fallait donc vous vous
rappelez l'aller 1 2 300 tonnes du
ouzbek member ben la zone adaptée
phallus ce sont les deux sangles stone
ici les degrés donc on appelle ça les
grès jumeaux letwin les twins hampton
c'est ce sont ces deux grecs on appelle
la ripelle mid sandton
donc c'est vraiment juste au dessus vous
pouvez voir de la zone acquis steak et
phallus et donc la ripelle mid
elle est au milieu de la zone adaptée
adaptiez phallus et ici les ou de
bergues les 310 tonnes la 2 août bergues
ce sont les 310 tôt enfin elles sont au
milieu de la zone à qui ce téké phallus
donc faut vous imaginer qu'en fait si on
n'avait pas les fossiles là pour
déterminer dans cet intervalle où se
trouve la fin de la première
ozone et où se trouve le début de la
seconde bah c'est pas la géologie qui
nous dira où elle se trouve cette limite
1 donc c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment
à ça que ça sert en fait là
biostratigraphie ça permet de mettre des
limites là où la géode là où la géologie
ne nous aide pas parce que dans l'absolu
sinon on aurait juste à servir ben oui
la série paul mid donc on n'a pas besoin
on ferait juste de la litho
stratigraphie en fait puisque quand on
utilise comme ça les cendres stone pour
se repérer on se confesse et de la litho
stratigraphie on utilise les couches
lite on utilise les couches de roches
pour se repérer mais par contre si on
voulait si on veut savoir où se trouve
le contact entre les bio zone il ya que
les fossiles qui peuvent l'indiquait
donc là tout ce qui se passe entre les
deux couches de sandston ici là
d'arythmie d'el al haouz bergues pour un
géologue
il se passe rien en fait alors que pour
nous envient ozonation il se passe
quelque chose il se passe la transition
entre d'ap tôt et qui s'était qu'il
fallut donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
utiliser tous les indices faut pas juste
utiliser la litho stratigraphie ou juste
les datation absolue au juste les
datations relatifs ont utilisé tous les
indices pour obtenir la division la plus
précise de toutes ces roches et quand on
combine tous les indices et bien on a
une vision complète plus complète en
tout cas donc voilà je vous parlais
justement de la différence entre dc nos
dons est apte au qu'il fallut donc ce
que les gens qui ont étudié disent
innocents et à stocker phallus on
remarquer c'est que d'apt au qu'il
fallut ça une crête sagittale que d'ici
nous donne n'a pas aidé ici nos dons a
les yeux à une vision binoculaire alors
que d'apt ok phallus lui a les yeux un
peu plus sur le côté voilà donc d'ici ne
donne est plus une chèvre et d'apt
auquel fallu c'est plus une vache
sinon ils sont extrêmement similaires
ils sont extrêmement similaire donc et
c'est le fossile de plus typique de la
zone adaptant qu'il fallait sans fin
dapd ok phallus ai dit 'si nous donne
sont les fossiles les plus typiques de
la zone adapte aux quais phallus sinon
la zone adapte aux quais phallus elle
est très très très très très similaire à
ce qu'on trouve dans la zone à kyste et
qu'il fallut mois les kystes est qu'il
fallut c'est évident
puisque qui s'était qu'elle phallus
marque la zone kiss & kill phallus mais
sinon les deux faune sont extrêmement
similaires la zone adapte aux quais
phallus est marqué par la diviser en
deux en fait donc away un truc que j'ai
pas dit mais c'est qu'on trouve aussi
des rubis jean dans la zone adapte aux
qu'il fallut cela comme je les dis les
gorgones obtient ce sont les prédateurs
dominant de tout le permis mais là en
l'occurrence ils sont pas utilisés
spécialement pour la vio stratigraphie
mais c'est pas parce que je ne mentionne
pas leur existence dans le diaporama qui
ne sont pas toujours là c'est et donc la
zone adapte aux qu'il fallut salle est
divisée en deux en deux zones
alors là sous zones qui commencerait
autour de 155 millions d'années et se
terminera autour de 253 millions
d'années qui hélas ouzou n'a dit si nos
dons et thériault natus est là sous zone
supérieure donc la soul zone j'ai envie
de dire terminal qui en fait marc le
début c'est le début de la fin en fait
pour le père vient à savoir le début de
la crise d'extinction de masse et donc
cette soudaine supérieur c'est la zone
a10 trop riche d'un cahier moscow rai
news corp amusé et là où elle est la
grosse différence dans les grosses
différences entre ces deux zones au
moins là pour le coup le nombre des
sous-zones veut dire exactement ce qui
veut dire c'est à dire que d'ici nos
dons et thériault de natus ne se
retrouve que dans la partie inférieure
est liste rose auris macheda et moscow
anus se retrouve que dans la partie
supérieure donc là pour le coup ah non
pas meuse quoi est dû ce autant pour moi
je ferais bien de regarder les figures
que je mets moi car elle ne se
retrouvent pas que la partie supérieure
mais bref l'important en fait
l'important la différence majeure en
fait entre les deux zones
la grosse différence j'ai envie de dire
c'est l'apparition de liste rose aux
russes la soul zone inférieure de la
zone adapte aux quais phallus n'a pas de
liste rose au russe est en fait c'est
l'apparition de liste rose aux russes
qui définit la soul au dessus
d'ailleurs et cette soudaine supérieur
comme je voulais dit c'est le début de
la fin pour le père bien l'apparition de
liste rose doris liste rose aux russes
c'est le le disaster saxon qui indique
qu'on entre dans la zone 2 dans la zone
de la limite permise trias donc la
fameuse crise d'extinction de masse du
permien trias là où 90% de ce qu'ils
vivent à mourir et donc l'apparition de
liste rose aux russes bassesse le
marqueur du début de la fin voilà donc
c'est ça qu'il faut redire et 10,3 au
russe il est très facile à identifier un
puisque il à ceux qui qui est tendu ces
indices hinault donc normal mais avec le
pif tordu c'est très facile à
reconnaître qu'en pareilles indices
hinault donne par exemple donc l'avoir
gardé dix si nos zones il a un crâne
relativement bas horizontal et liste
rose aux russes que vous voyez là bas
c'est comme un dc nos dogmes avec le
crâne qui d'un seul coup boom fait ça
braff et du coup ça les rend très très
très facile à identifier donc là la
grosse différence entre les deux zones
c'est l'apparition de liste roseaux
rouges dans la zone supérieure
c'est surtout ça qu'il faut retenir donc
pareil quand on trouve des dix synodaux
ailleurs dans les autres roches
par exemple en europe ou en russie ça
permet de faire des corrélations avec ce
qu'on a
en afrique du sud même en l'absence de
datation absolue pour ces couches là
mais nous ici en afrique du sud on a des
datation absolue notamment pour la fin
du permien fin du permien qui est très
très bien dater vu que c'est la fameuse
extinction de masse la crise permien
trias donc encore une fois beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'études qui se sont
penchés sur le sujet est beaucoup
beaucoup études qui ont du coup fournit
des lattes encore que c'est pas
évidemment exemple de discussion donc on
va se laisser sur un coût non on va se
quitter sur un cliffhanger à savoir la
limite permise trias voilà la prochaine
fois nous parlerons de la limite permise
trias et de ce qui se passe à la limite
permise à trias et puis nous attaquerons
ensuite la biostratigraphie
ihas est celle du jurassique et nous
conclurons à la semaine prochaine